I think at this point you guys probably
know I'm big on this free speech thing
I'm a firm believer that you can say
absolutely anything you want period that
doesn't mean there won't be consequences
for what you say but you have the right
to say what you want by the same token
others have the right to rebut your free
speech by exercising theirs
this is how good ideas win not by
stifling bad speech but by beating it
with better ideas as I've mentioned many
times in America right this very moment
I'm not that concerned that the
government is coming for my free speech
you can say pretty much anything you
want about the government without fear
and in many cases you'll look cool for
fighting the power there are instances
like Edward Snowden and the CIA leaks
where it seems people are being
persecuted for speech but really those
consequences are for exposing state
secrets however what I fear in America
is that we are taking away speech from
ourselves and we are doing it in a
plethora of ways you guys all know about
the safe spaces and the trigger warnings
on college campuses which are designed
to shield young people from speech which
might scare them now authors with
controversial ideas are de platformed
and speakers who dare bring up a
contrarian thought are shouted down it's
not just colleges though we also have
protesters blocking roads to political
rallies because they don't like what
might be said before it actually is
throwing the overuse of the words like
racist bigoted homophobic sexist and you
have a toxic mess designed to shut down
any important and honest discussion in
other countries the threat to free
speech is much worse than we have it
here America has plenty of so-called
allies who don't respect free speech in
a myriad of ways many Islamic countries
have laws against blasphemy and apostasy
meaning you can be put in jail or even
killed for mocking God or leaving
religion and the oppression of women
minorities gays and others into the mix
and you have entire societies that not
only don't have freedom of speech but
are actively trying to control what
their citizens think and
they act we often think that the most
backwards countries related to free
speech and these intolerant ideas are in
the Middle East but often that's not the
case my guest this week is Amos Yee Amos
is a seventeen year old from Singapore
who is an atheist and free speech
advocate
mo shares his thoughts about government
religion and more right here on YouTube
for the entire world to see
hey mo Scott on my radar just a couple
days ago when I started getting dozens
of tweets asking me to help him after he
was arrested due to Singapore's
blasphemy laws at this very moment he's
out on $5,000 bail and awaiting trial in
Singapore he faces five counts of
wounding the religious feelings of
Muslims and one count of wounding the
religious feelings of Christians if
convicted he faces up to three years in
prison
I've caught up on some of Amos as videos
and this is a guy who pulls absolutely
no punches I've seen videos of him
mocking and licking the Koran I've seen
him humping the Bible and plenty of
other stuff he's mocking others ideas
with ideas of his own he isn't calling
for harm to a person or group of people
he's in fact doing the most human thing
you can do which is thinking for
yourself as ayaan Hirsi Ali says if you
are for minorities you must be for
minorities within those minorities this
is the perfect example of that if you
really are for atheists or free thinkers
then you must be for the brave ones who
mock the very institutions which would
have them jailed or killed
you can't just be for ideas when it's
safe you have to be for ideas when it's
your own life on the line Amos is not
only a living example of that concept
but he's also putting it all out on
YouTube for the world to see if he's
brave enough to do that then the rest of
us have a duty to use our free speech to
amplify his message if we're afraid to
do that then it's our speech the
authoritarians will come for next